the jurogan experience
do you see what's going on with china
with that female tennis star yeah
yeah um jamie stevie will pull that
story up it's uh this this woman
apparently
she uh said that she was sexually abused
by some politician correct yeah and then
did you see like the hostage note that
she wrote no i didn't know oh so she
wrote a note that says
hello world i am fine everything is okay
if you want to print anything else about
me please run it through me everything
is okay i am fine i mean i'm
paraphrasing but super weird super weird
the kind of the kind of thing that you
write when someone's holding a gun to
your head and it was just a note it
wasn't a video it was yeah it's a note
it's a it's a document you know an
electronic document
bro they ghost people over there oh oh
for sure they do where is
how do you say your name
huai uh disappears after accusing
government official of sexual assault
wow
spooky [ __ ] but from there's something
where the united states tennis
association
said that they're they were willing to
lose hundreds of millions of dollars
um worth of business with chyna
if if she doesn't show up again
here it is the women's tennis
association
uh in all societies behavior she alleges
took place needs to be investigated not
condoned or ignored
um
we command peng sh
feng
for her remarkable courage and strength
and coming forward women around the
world so there was uh
someone
recently
some tennis organization recently
um i believe it was today said something
that they were going to uh boycott
um playing and and doing business with
china until she shows up here it says
the letter hello everyone this is peng
shui
regarding the recent news released on
the official website of wta the content
has not been confirmed or verified by
myself
and it was released without my consent
the news in that release including the
allegation of sexual assault is not true
i'm not missing nor am i unsafe i've
just been resting at home and everything
is fine
thank you again for caring about me oh
jesus christ
right
i hope the last part i hope to promote
chinese tennis with all of with you all
if i have the chance in the future if i
have the chance i hope chinese tennis
will become better and better
i mean the the fact that we're buying
stuff from that country and then we buy
so much from that country we know this
human rights abuse is going on over
there we know it it's a fact oh it's
definitely a fact um
you know i i i got uh shadow band
recently on
some of the social media sites and how
do you know
uh so a bunch of people there's two two
ways i know a bunch of people started it
started a little while ago people saying
hey i can't find you i tried to search
for you you're not appearing in my
what's it called uh feed you're not i'm
not seeing my feed and then finally
people started sending me videos of
they'd search for
search for at jocko willink and it
wouldn't pop up mean you wouldn't see my
you wouldn't see my mind i'll try to my
search for you right now let's see if i
can get well it's been healed up oh
really so one way i knew was because of
that the other way i knew is because
uh friends with insider information
people that are on the inside of these
organizations but
you know and i wasn't really 100 i was
trying to think why
why would i get
why would i get shadow banned right it
didn't make a lot of sense to me i don't
i mean look i put pictures of sweat and
yeah i watched your watch
so
but on my podcast sometimes i'll go a
little bit hard sometimes and or at
least talk about some subjects that
maybe some people aren't too happy about
i did one about the
the the the chinese what they're doing
with the uyghurs and
basically you know it's genocide of
sorts going on with the uyghurs which is
like a
uh uh an ethnic group in china
muslim at the ethnic group they they're
and they're getting
yeah they're getting wiped out shipped
off to the camps
no one knows what's happening to them
yep yep no accountability
so that was one uh then i did another
podcast with uh with a friend of mine
daryl cooper and
we were we were talking about and
there's another guy named brian suits
and we were talking about these movies
these these chinese movies that are out
right now and they're some of the most
popular movies in
in the world and one's called wolf
warrior and the other one's called wolf
warrior two
and there you can you can see these you
can you can google them but they're
they're these propaganda films
where
like the chinese wolf warrior this is a
pack of sort of elite chinese commandos
and they fight americans
and the americans that they fight
generally are navy seals so
and and
like the closing scene i haven't watched
the whole movies but the the closing
scene i think it's a wolf warrior two
is this chinese hero
fighting against this navy seal american
like hand-to-hand combat and by the way
they're fighting to free these there's
other people that are kind of in cages
looking on and it's the chinese
individuals fighting for the for the
glory and for the freedom of these other
people and the american is fighting for
some big corporate greed scenario
yeah it's very strange there it is is
that frank grillo yep
frank grillos and wolf warriors he's in
well four years too frank
what are you doing so so they're they're
they're making propaganda films
anti-american propaganda films and and
the thing that's scary about this is
you know china is thinking very
strategically about things yeah they're
thinking about how to defeat america in
20 years or 25 years
and
that's what they're thinking about
that's what they're planning for that's
why they're making films like this
and what is america thinking about
we're thinking about the next election
cycle that's what we're thinking about
yeah oh stabbed him in the eyeball he's
dead
now he's gonna say something mean to him
he says
that's [ __ ] history somebody said
okay so this is what's what's crazy is
that they're making uh anti-american
propaganda films and we are making films
that are run through the chinese
government to make sure that certain
things aren't offensive
that's what's scary they're changing
marvel comics characters you know that
like doctor strange what are they
changing dr strange
dr strange was a
physician who had this accident and then
went and studied with this tibetan
mystic and developed all these
supernatural powers right
china doesn't believe in tibet doesn't
believe tibet should have any freedom so
instead of a tibetan mystic it's uh a
woman and she's got a shaved head
and it's a white woman
so that this is his mystic now instead
of it being a tibetan mystic it's some
white lady
they changed the [ __ ] origin story of
the comic book yep
china they got another movie that's
coming out that's about the chosen
reservoir and
you know this famous battle in the in
the korean war where america got
surrounded and and had to fight their
way out it eventually came back and and
fought and you know settled on the the
38th parallel
but in the movie it's this just total
glory for china you know sending the
americans back to the sea they they
changed they they're like you said
they're changing history and they're
trying to set us up but what they're
setting us up for is
a lot they're thinking long term they're
thinking about 20 years from now how are
they going to be able to defeat us and
as we see all the time
one of the ways that they are moving to
defeat us is by dividing us that's the
goal
get into our social media
and try and cause as much division as
possible and
it works
you